it breaks my heart my friends like live
for Friday night like they know they get
their wait like Monday morning is the
worst it's just a huge percentage of
one's life I can't wrap my head around
with the internet this is not your
grandpappy's life we have the Internet
you can make [ __ ] happen you can build
businesses or side hustles I just don't
understand why people relegate into
losing mentality and just thinking they
can't you can't because you want to be
on the bowling team or softball and play
video games that's why you can't there's
plenty of time gets [ __ ] done the level
of complaining is unacceptable look what
if I told you this was the last Monday
morning of your life what if I go do you
die this week would you complain about
your crap job or that test you don't
want to take I doubt it
you'd go much higher level thinking well
that's really what it takes it takes
understanding that if you're not pumped
right now if you're begrudging what
you're about to do is here if you're not
looking forward please recognize the
world we're living in we're living in a
world where is so much more opportunity
this internet thing created way more
opportunity for all of us way more I
mean look you might not even be alive
like your mom and dad could have had sex
like three minutes later and you
wouldn't even exist and you're
complaining you could have ended up
being a bus a tree I just don't get the
mentality of being head down sad on a
Monday morning I'm gonna make Monday
morning my [ __ ] I'm gonna make you
Saturday Monday morning that's what I
want to do every morning
and that's what I want from you please
take a step back and think about how
awesome it actually is and then
recognize that you can attack the world
in a totally different way because you
were lucky enough to be born during this
era
you